how's it going bros my name is Peter and
today we're going to play with VR I'm
not wearing the suit this time because
he burrows thought it was too weird but
I have a new suit don't worry
let's change
this one is for you mark said this one
is for you wait I'm in the horror movie
wait this is a horror game that [ __ ]
this I'm not playing this [ __ ] [ __ ]
okay this is Paranormal Activity thanks
to we artworks we get to get an
exclusive look at this game look at my
hands I have got the touch of a ghost I
can feel it
rising up from above and people have
already disliked this video alright I'm
just kidding alright here we go whoa I
move like this what the [ __ ] is this eh
okay he needs batteries and grabby
can you kill someone playing my
headphones hello is anyone there alright
guys we need to find the batteries hey
lady you look good
can I kiss your baby is that weed that's
right for [ __ ] sake it's so [ __ ]
dumb alright we're gonna we're gonna
walk down here gonna grab you whoa
that's cool man Oh
perhaps in here oh wow that's cool man
okay alright we don't need that here we
go let's go in here hi guys what's up
can't even turn on the faucet what
[ __ ] Christ I don't even want this kid
alright we got a key guys oh my lord
what up [ __ ] let's put a pad okay
don't worry we got a book Hey okay we
can read the book
all right so the satanic symbols clock
there's a key the clock you piece of
[ __ ] hey there mister clock okay so we
got to set the timer No oh nice is good
this is cool this is good come on buddy
hey get the thing is anything gonna
happen I mean I didn't do anything did I
send one out there shut up already the
walking is so [ __ ] weird okay we got
a lighter oh oh so now we can read the
book properly this is cool man
so we set the watch on 12 someone Satan
next step got it
hi guys what's going on put a pipe hey
this is lovely
look at this oh man you made it all
pretty and [ __ ] okay whatever guy nice
dress we got anything up there oh
there's the demon there's a demon thing
all right okay we got to find something
to sacrifice the Satan hey what's up in
here what the [ __ ] is this hey Teddy how
you're doing you're coming with me take
what's your real name Angelina Jolie are
you coming with me buddy all right so
how does this make you feel all right
well Angelina I'm sorry we're gonna have
to sacrifice you to Satan that's dude Oh
Jeff now what the [ __ ] was that they
were Satan listen I will burn you I
can't burn [ __ ] oh god damn it Angelina
all right so we're gonna put Angelina
right here there we go now you be a good
girl stay right there
now Satan should be here any minute
oh my god what the [ __ ] was that oh god
where's my flashlight where's my key
there it is compare cichlid goddamn it
Angelina you piece of [ __ ] you're coming
with me
you coming with me you're trash Angie
don't you [ __ ] dare be behind me
you check Angie who does that [ __ ]
alright we're going together Angie it's
you and me it's your and me edgy you
said you loved Brad you [ __ ] idiot i
redecorated for you [ __ ] you alright
Angie you check if it's safe it's safe
pierced you liar excuse me
what the [ __ ] is there a girl what are
you doing hey yes what is it you [ __ ]
whatever I don't I don't [ __ ] care
did I pee a little bit yeah but whatever
it's cool oh my god
okay that's fine give me the [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] it's fine
Angie there you are you [ __ ] [ __ ]
okay what do we got this we're going in
here
okay let's not go in there let's go here
okay you're my only friend that is this
[ __ ] all right we're going hello
was that you ng know who [ __ ] said
that okay all right just take it easy
we're taking it easy Angie all right I
almost died Jesus Christ okay we're fine
hey how you doing well I hope you
enjoyed this gameplay leave a like if
you enjoyed I don't want to play more
how long did I record that was the game
oh my god I did oh what a piece of [ __ ]
yeah I mean what a great game what a
great game where's my sunglasses when a
game isn't even that scary
that's when you know booty pie is lying
y'all ladies you want a real man I get
scared that doesn't get scared that's me
I don't get scared
what's up call me don't call my ex yeah
call me yeah yeah you keep filming there
keep filming there bread this game was
really cool I like the idea that you're
in it you feel like you're in the horror
you're standing up you're all alone it
got me it got me good let me know if you
want me to do more of this game we would
like if you did if you do and I'll see
you Bros in the next video brofist
what are you baby Gama